quantis anne-marie nous fois un bon
petit meuble est à hâter à col collet
totalité lobis loto ledl faux et rit
c'est de la poésie sur du rythme
un style auquel plusieurs collégiens du
nord et de l'est se sont essayés le
résultat le voici un album concocté dans
le cadre d'une résidence de création à
la bibliothèque départementale tira le
chanteur à jouer les coachs et pousser
des marmailles à raconter leur époque
oui ça s'est choisi on a regardé autour
de nous pose moi ce qui est bien ou pas
on a fait ce projet par rapport à notre
caractère
on a tous réfléchir pour écrire les
paroles et où et comment tu trouves cet
album là tu as écouté tous tout en
entier vie était très bien
j'adore oui ça fait du bien et
s'exprimer de pouvoir dire ce qu'on
ressent suffisamment quand la place
nous sommes des talons nude domestique
est perdu dans les méandres de la vie à
la quête de l'artiste en classe bulis ou
segpa
chacun de ces collégiens a écrit une
phrase de l'album le vinyle n'est pas à
vendre
il raconte la jeunesse à la réunion en
2020 qui on a confronté des enfants les
enfants des classes à un livre qui
s'appelle les maraudes de louis
t'imagines watts pour s'informer de
quelle position avec les esclaves dans
la cour du maître pourquoi des esclaves
avaient une place pourquoi des esclaves
ça veut dire pourquoi donc ne savez pas
lire
donc à partir de là je leur ai dit vous
vous me sortez ça parce qu'on vous dit
on dit de vous vous savez pas lire ne
savait pas écrire ça n'est pas tout ça
donc qu'est ce que vous savez dit man le
fond de votre coeur l'objectif c'est de
faire dialoguer patrimoine en tout cas
en ce qui concerne bibliothèque le
patrimoine imprimés de la réunion et des
créateurs d'instaurer
une espèce de réciprocité dans la
pratique culturelle en général auprès
des publics les plus éloignés de la
culture également nous voudrons arrête
la malle détendu tout demoun n'ouvrez
légalité des balles
les nouveautés
bonnet
l'album s'appelle créole des mots bruts
pour un fonds de coeur rythmé où les
enfants n'ont pas manqué d'ambition